feuerentfernung am 21 februar in einem
Gebäudekomplex in Essen 36 Wohnungen
stehen komplett in Flammen
130 Bewohner können sich gerade noch in
Sicherheit bringen besonders kritisch
war es für den Physiker Marcel Preuß er
wohnte im ersten Stock und lag im Bett
es war nachts gegen 3 Uhr
gingen tatsächlich die Rauchmelder an
und zum gleichen Moment tatsächlich hat
man auch schon die Flammen wahrgenommen
durch die Jalousien ist es auf den
Balkon entlang gekrochen relativ flott
und schnell das Feuer breitet sich
rasend schnell aus Marcel Preuß hat
seine Rettung mutigen Nachbarn zu
verdanken
das war ja für mich die erste Etage und
insofern keine Aufzug Treppen alleine
schwierig die beiden Nachbarn die
bereits auch tatsächlich schon in Panik
unterwegs waren haben wir denn beide
geholfen
und dann sind wir relativ schnell drei
Stufen auf einmal nehmen die Treppe
runter ich bin mir ziemlich sicher wäre
ich nicht an dem Abend noch wach gewesen
dann hätte ich nicht genug Zeit gehabt
Ende September mehr als sieben Monate
danach liegt immer noch kein offizielles
Brandgutachten vor deshalb werden
Interviews gegenüber frontal abgelehnt
vom Hauseigentümer vivawest von der
Feuerwehr und auch von der Essener
Bauaufsicht
Hans hiltemann wohnt direkt gegenüber
der Brandruine er hat noch gut in
Erinnerung wie das Feuer gewütet hat
die Polizei hat an die Tür geklopft und
habe ich mal geguckt und dann war es
schon dort auf dem ersten Stock und dann
ja wird es ungefähr so das waren nicht
mehr aus fünf Minuten da stand die ganze
Fassade in Flammen ja und ja wir hatten
Angst für die Leute
so stellt sich die Frage warum hat sich
das Feuer in wenigen Minuten aufs ganze
Gebäude ausgedehnt und warum dieser
extreme Funkenregen
Spurensuche auf der Rückseite der
Brandruine sind bis heute durchgängig
montierte Platten aus Plexiglas
angebracht
also Kunststoff hergestellt aus Erdöl
und damit brennbar mit diesem Plexiglas
waren große Teile der Fassade des
brandgebäudes verkleidet so wie hier
beim Nachbargebäude
und genau diese Plexiglasplatten
brannten lichterloh wie diese Fotos
zeigen nach dem Brand wickelte Uwe
Eichner Geschäftsführer der
Wohnungsgesellschaft vivawest erst
einmal ab
wir sind der Meinung und haben bisher
auch keine Anhaltspunkte dafür dass das
verbaute Material nicht richtig wäre
oder ein falsches wäre erstaunlich
wenige Wochen später ließ vivawest die
Plexiglasplatten am Nachbargebäude
demontieren
Plexiglas gilt baurechtlich als normal
entflammbar bedeutet es brennt
eigenständig weiter
als Fassadenverkleidung an
Mehrfamilienhäusern ist es grundsätzlich
nicht zugelassen denn dort müssen
Fassaden schwer entflammbar sein
merkwürdig nur nach deutschem Baurecht
gehören Balkone aber nicht zur Fassade
inzwischen hat Eigentümer vivawest
selbst Bedenken und teilschriftlich mit
Zitat
mit der Baubehörde wurde abgestimmt dass
der Balkon Sichtschutz aus
Plexiglasplatten entfernt wird aus
vorsorglichen Sicherheitsgründen
Hans hiltemann zeigt uns seinen
sanierten Balkon die Trennwände aus
Plexiglas wurden durch
Zementfaserplatten ausgetauscht dazu 50
cm Blech auf dem Boden der übrige
Balkonboden aber besteht immer noch aus
brennbarem Material
wpc-profile ein Holz-
haben sie gar keine Sorgen
ja ein bisschen natürlich ich hoffe dass
das nicht geschieht wieder ja wenn läuft
Vermieter vivawest legt Wert auf die
Feststellung
obwohl Plexiglas und
wpc-bauaufsichtlich zugelassen sind
werden diese Materialien bis zur genauen
Klärung des brandherrgangs nicht verbaut
doch ob das brennbare WPC vollständig
ausgetauscht wird aufhält man es und
anderen Balkonen das lässt vivawest
offen
kunststoffhaltige wpc-profile sind im
Balkon und Terrassenbau sehr verbreitet
in vielen Baumärkten werden Sie günstig
angeboten wir wollen wissen wie leicht
es ist solche WPC-Dielen in Brand zu
setzen
Dachdeckermeister Ernst kaprolat aus
Geilenkirchen hilft uns dabei mit einem
für Dacharbeiten üblichen Schweißbrenner
nach nur wenigen Sekunden brennen die
wpc-paneele lichterloh wie eine Fackel
brennt sehr schnell muss man
sollte mal vorsichtig mit sein das würde
ich auf keinen Fall auf Balkone legen
dann würde ich lieber
Betonplatten nehmen im Kölner
Jugendzentrum Glashütte haben im Mai
ebenfalls
wpc-bodenprofile Feuer gefangen eine
einzelne Zigarettenkippe soll diese
Kunststoffbretter auf der Dachterrasse
in Brand gesetzt haben
die Feuerwehr konnte durch schnelles
Eingreifen Schlimmeres verhindern
berichtet Tanja Schmieder ihr Büro liegt
direkt an der Brandstelle
also hier waren halt dieser WPC auf der
ganzen Terrasse und hier war aber auch
eine Raucherecke und zwar mir immer
bewusst und ich habe immer gesagt dass
es gefährlich Leute macht das nicht hier
in der Ecke ja und dann ist es dann doch
passiert
wie kommen normal in flammenbare
Baustoffe an Fassaden obwohl sie laut
Gesetz da nicht hingehören
denn Gesetzesgrundlage ist die
Musterbauordnung hier heißt es Zitat
Oberflächen von Außenwänden sowie
Außenwandbekleidungen müssen
einschließlich der Dämmstoffe und
Unterkonstruktionen schwer in flammbar
sein Problem nur schwer in flammenbar
gilt nicht für Balkone doch genau daran
haben in Essen die Flammen gewütet weil
sie mit Plexiglas und WPC umhüllt waren
war also diese juristische Grauzone
Mitschuld für das plötzliche Flammenmeer
in Essen
wir fragen nach bei Nordrhein-Westfalens
bauministerin Ina scharrenbach
für die Balkone gibt es andere
Brandschutzanforderungen als wir
Fassaden warum wir haben insbesondere in
Essen auch einen windenereignis im
besonderen Maße gehabt wo eben Gutachter
auch sagen das hat noch mal die Brand
Ausbreitung deutlich beschleunigt so wir
schauen uns natürlich sowohl die Frage
der Balkone an als auch das Unterbodens
der eingesetzt wurde und möglicherweise
auch zu einer Beschleunigung beigetragen
hat das ist aber eben noch nicht
abgeschlossen was sagen Experten zu
diesem brandgefährlichen Kunststoffen an
Fassaden auf der feuerwehrmesse
Interschutz in Hannover treffen wir
Peter Bachmeier der Experte für
vorbeugenden Brandschutz deutscher
Berufsfeuerwehren um die
Jahrtausendwende hatten die Balkone
schon eine Anforderungen
Platte musste genauso ausgeführt werden
wie die Decken im Gebäude hier hat mir
Erleichterungen gemacht vor etwa 20
Jahren
Vorschriften wurden gelockert auch um
einfaches und billiges bauen möglich zu
machen Deregulierung auf Kosten des
Brandschutzes
also es ist heute möglich dass sie
balkonia aus brennbaren Baustoffen
errichten und somit aber der
feuerübersprung also über die brennbaren
Materialien des Balkons ja nie ermöglich
ist oder leichter ist leute lasst die
finger feuerleichterungen weil sie
werden diese Auswirkungen haben
130 Menschen haben ihr Hab und Gut
verloren der Brand in Essen hat gezeigt
dass wir auf jeden Fall die Balkone auf
den Prüfstand stellen müssen die
Brandkatastrophe von Essen macht klar
der Gesetzgeber muss handeln